[Music]
on this friday night the intensifying
pressure to save afghans from the
taliban
[Music]
the push for canada to do more and act
faster washington's confidence in its
evacuation plan as those who helped us
wait they will kill me a pledge for paid
sick leave what the liberals are
promising and why the ndp isn't buying
it in israel a high covet vaccination
rate and now one of the world's highest
infection rates the remedy and the
warning to canada and a story we all
need right now that's beyond my wildest
dreams a boy a basketball and the
neighbors giving him a shot at a great
future
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
as canada's political parties campaign
for your votes we are going to start in
afghanistan with the thousands of people
who have heard the promise canada will
take them in but fear they'll be left
behind to be hunted down by the taliban
this is the legacy of the end of
america's longest war stun grenades
fired to try and hold back the crush of
people who still crowd the perimeter of
kabul airport babies and children lifted
over the razor wire to save them from
being crushed and trampled the u.s
marine corps posted these photos from
inside the airport compound soldiers
cradling babies nato says more than 18
thousand people have been flown out of
the city since the taliban took over the
capital five days ago many of them are
foreign diplomats their families and
citizens of other countries they are
given first priority thousands of those
who risk their lives working for western
countries still wait we're told a
canadian military evacuation flight did
leave kabul last night defense officials
say 175 vulnerable afghans and 13
foreign nationals were on board and they
say 1 000 afghan nationals at risk of
retribution for their work with canada
and other allied countries have been
flown out so far there is intense
pressure to do more and act faster this
open letter from the canadian
association for refugee and forced
migration studies calls on all the
federal party leaders to expedite the
resettlement process for 20 thousand
afghans and to evacuate those afghans
and their families who urgently require
protection
we have been working closely with our
allies particularly with the u.s and the
uk
on ensuring that we are as effective as
possible all together on bringing out as
many afghans as possible and getting
people to safety given the very
difficult crisis right now
the taliban controls the routes to the
airport in kabul there are reports today
the u.s military used helicopters to
ferry 96 afghans over those taliban
checkpoints to the airport there is no
word whether canada is planning to do
the same abigail beeman has the latest
on canada's actions in afghanistan
abigail
donna the liberal government has been
heavily criticized on the campaign trail
for not doing enough to get more people
out of afghanistan faster and even for
the timing of calling an election in the
first place given the number of people
whose lives are at risk the airport is
flooded with people trying to escape
friday justin trudeau is on the defense
once again saying he's briefed daily on
the evolving situation but he wouldn't
clearly answer whether special forces
are going outside the airport to help
find people in kabul who are at risk and
help get them onto flights as some of
our allies are doing not going to
comment on operational matters for
reasons of security but i will say
that our
our forces uh and our uh our
our partners uh are doing absolutely
everything necessary to get as many
people out as quickly as possible
conservatives are criticizing the
liberals for not doing enough fast
enough when the taliban's rise didn't
exactly happen overnight we asked aaron
o'toole today whether he would insist
people have proper documentation that
and general communication from the
government to people on the ground
trying to get out has been a big issue
we've been asking for five
years to bring back
interpreters contractors that are at
risk because they helped canada
so let's get them out of that risk as
soon as possible and sort out the
the paperwork later there are also
questions around how many people canada
is willing to put on each evacuation
flight who's allowed on those flights
and when they will depart donna all
right abigail beamon in winnipeg tonight
thank you american president joe biden
said today his administration is focused
on getting americans out of afghanistan
by august 31st he says he is also
committed to trying to evacuate as many
afghan interpreters and others who
assisted the u.s government a goal that
biden said was equally important almost
they passed the 31st to make that happen
to bring all the americans out to bring
those sivs out i think we can get it
done by then but we're going to make
that judgment as we
go in the meantime the taliban is
consolidating power it has placed
security for the afghan capital in the
hands of senior members of the haqqani
network which has close ties with
foreign jihadist groups including a
long-standing association with al qaeda
jackson proskow looks at what is
unfolding in afghanistan
outside the kabul airport civilians beg
for a chance at freedom passing infants
across barbed wire
the growing crowd at times pushed back
by afghan soldiers who fire into the air
that chaos extends to the tarmac where
thousands spent the day stuck in the hot
sun
flights were suspended for hours because
of deteriorating conditions in qatar the
facility where evacuees were being taken
reached capacity resources were
overwhelmed there'd be plenty of time to
criticize and second guess when this
operation is over but now
now
i'm focused on getting this job done
u.s president joe biden acknowledged the
difficulties but vowed safe exit for
americans allies and the afghans who
helped them he insisted the taliban is
cooperating and allowing safe passage to
the airport to the best of our knowledge
the taliban checkpoints they are letting
through
people showing american passports
those on the ground tell a different
story
afghan interpreter omit mammoth worked
with u.s forces and fears for his life
if he can't escape they will kill me and
they will behave me as a foreigner um
i mean i'm nervous i'm absolutely
nervous because
we can't trust the taliban yet
australian filmmaker jordan bryan has no
plans to leave kabul
documenting the women who bravely
celebrated afghan independence day in
defiance of the taliban
fearing the situation will only
deteriorate in the weeks to come they've
just waltzed on in and taken over and it
just it just can't be this easy like
there has to be really dark days to come
already u.s troops have gone over the
wall at the airport to rescue dozens of
american citizens
other nations have brought in
helicopters to airlift their citizens to
safety
the forces that invaded and occupied
afghanistan for more than two decades
are in a hasty retreat
knowing the chaos of today may pale in
comparison to the turmoil that could
come
jackson prosko global news washington
many canadians are watching the
situation in afghanistan closely and at
the same time the pandemic has not ended
more than 64 percent of canadians are
now double vaccinated but covet 19 cases
are now soaring in parts of canada the
fourth wave which public health
officials have been warning about for
months has taken hold the highly
transmissible delta variant is driving
the surge there are more than 22 000
active cases in canada now 753 people
are in the hospital up just slightly
from yesterday and it is in the west
that the highest rate of active cases
per 100 000 people exists the northwest
territories has seen the sharpest rise
in infections there are now at least 169
active cases there last week there was
only one an outbreak has been declared
at a long-term care home two communities
have public health emergencies in effect
and are pleading for government help
this week marks the first time the delta
variant has been detected in the
northwest territories
one measure the federal government
brought in during the pandemic could be
permanent if the liberals are re-elected
leader justin trudeau made that promise
today ripping a page from the ndp our
chief political correspondent david
aiken is traveling with the liberal
campaign david
well donna liberal leader justin trudeau
promised today that if re-elected he
will make 10 days of paid sick leave
available to federally regulated workers
and that would make permanent what had
been a temporary measure brought in
during the pandemic as a government and
as this country's largest employer it's
up to us to set the example trudeau also
promised to negotiate with the provinces
to extend paid sick leave to all sectors
the ndp immediately pounced on this
promise saying they proposed precisely
this measure 18 months ago and the
trudeau government never acted on it the
liberals are also promising to make an
extra 100 million dollars available to
schools to improve air ventilation
systems public health officials say
that's one key way to limit the spread
of the airborne virus our kids
have to be safe in our classrooms
that's non-negotiable
and their teachers and school staff well
they have to be safe too finally trudeau
was asked about the us decision to keep
its land border closed to non-essential
canadian travelers for another 30 days
until at least september 21st we will
work together as much as possible to
coordinate and make sure things are
going well but every country gets to
make its own decisions about how to best
keep canada and keep their citizens safe
true to his election team will have an
off day saturday and be back on the
election trail sunday donna all right
david aiken in winnipeg thanks the
federal ndp leader stopped in
saskatchewan today and was overcome with
emotion at one point jagmeet singh
visited the site where 751 unmarked
graves were discovered at the site of a
former residential school michael
couture is following the ndp campaign
a solemn walk through the unmarked
graves of the residential school of
kaoussis first nation jagmeet singh his
wife and the first nations chief cad ms
delorme used the moment to underscore
the work still needed on reconciliation
i commit to this with everything i can
with every ounce of of strength i have i
will fight for justice for indigenous
people the ndp leader says past
governments haven't done nearly enough a
refrain opposition parties have repeated
for decades
something not lost on chief delorme you
know i encourage government of canada
to to to work more quicker and provide
the strength for indigenous nations to
come up with the solutions all parties
have committed to walk the road to
reconciliation with indigenous
communities during this election
campaign
advocates say they want more than just
promises they want systemic change i
think that
the way that the system is set up makes
us look like beggars and squatters in
our own country
and that's not the way it should be the
last liberal budget did commit 18
billion dollars over five years to help
improve the quality of life in
indigenous communities
trudeau acknowledges more must be done i
think
that everyone shares
their impatience my impatience
to get even more done even faster on
reconciliation
but what took generations and in some
cases even centuries to break
will take more than a few years to fix
indigenous leaders from manitoba agree
it can't happen overnight but they say
the discovery of mass graves near the
sites of former residential schools
prove we are still at the start of the
process but we have to get to the truth
without truth there is no reconciliation
and looking at that truth in canada
canadians have to see what that truth is
before there can be any reconciliation
conservative leader erin o'toole echoed
that sentiment adding all canadians want
to see action on reconciliation
after a summer that saw so much pain in
indigenous communities michael couture
global news kawasa's first nation
saskatchewan
getting as many people back to work is
key for canada's road to economic
recovery and today on the campaign trail
conservative leader erin o'toole
unveiled a plan to create jobs promising
to cover between 25 and 50 percent of
salaries for new hires for six months if
he's elected 50 percent will be for
people that have been unemployed for
more than 10 months we need to work with
employers to hire those people to give
all canadians a chance
the conservative leader says his canada
job surge plan will apply to all
business sectors and will replace the
liberals canada emergency wage subsidy
which ends in october
israel tackles a new coveted spike
coming up what it could signal to the
rest of the world
israel set the pace for vaccinations
early in this pandemic quickly
administering doses to most adults but
now israel is facing a worrying fourth
wave and the rest of the world is
watching it's not that vaccines don't
work they do but their effect could
diminish over time and in the face of
the more contagious variants redmond
shannon explains
this is how israeli prime minister
naftali bennett wants to tackle the
fourth wave of covet 19 in israel
booster shots rather than another
lockdown he and other 40-somethings
became eligible for third doses friday
we from israel are going to share all
the data
all the information all the insights the
absence of a full lockdown this time has
likely contributed to the sharp rise in
infections but so too has the apparent
waning effectiveness of the pfizer
biontech vaccine against the delta
variant just 39 according to israeli
figures last month newer numbers say
that jumps to 86 percent for people over
60 who've had a booster the third
booster shot is important to overcome
the
waning immunity that we see among the
elderly who have received their shots
over five months ago given israel's
early speed of rolling out initial doses
that waning immunity is a warning sign
to countries like canada especially as
the colder months approach boosting is
logical it should be implemented
immunologist jonathan gershone says
waning effectiveness is to be expected
what's encouraging is that two doses
remain highly effective against serious
cases of covet 19.
deaths in israel appear to be lower than
in the previous wave how is the vaccine
meeting the challenge of so many
repeats in attempts to infect
it's it's a numbers game but i don't
think that we should be overly concerned
this week the world health organization
again criticized plans for booster doses
saying there's not enough scientific
evidence to prove they're needed
high-income countries have already on
average administered more than 103 doses
per 100 people whereas in africa that
number stands at six ontario announced
this week it's giving boosters to the
most vulnerable germany and the united
states plan rollouts in september
redmond shannon global news london
still ahead for undecided voters one
thing is clear federal parties can't
afford to ignore money matters
now here is the executive producer of
jeopardy
mike richards
his starring role lasted just nine days
mike richards has stepped down as the
new host of jeopardy clips resurfaced
featuring him making disparaging
comments about women and other
marginalized groups on a podcast
richards was picked after a search that
included trial runs with sports figures
and celebrities he says he had no say in
his own selection but that moving
forward as host is not the right move
for the show he is reportedly staying on
as executive producer and the search
will resume for another host
well as we approach september canadians
have a lot on their minds the federal
election is a big one for many with
affordability and the rising cost of
living among the top issues tonight ann
gaviola looks at the impact on canadians
and what people say they want federal
leaders to do about it
monique gordon was laid off from her job
as a security guard during the pandemic
a job she'd had for 17 years two key
issues for her in this election housing
specifically for renters like her and
affordable accessible child care if i
can get a day care easily accessible
like close by so i can work any shift
without having to be modified that'll be
super great she's undecided but leaning
towards one party i would say
jag meet sing
because he challenges
justin trudeau according to the latest
ipsos polling the conservatives have
emerged as the number one choice among
respondents when it comes to the economy
ahead of the liberals while the ndp take
the top spot on matters of affordability
and the cost of living
between unprecedented government
spending a jaw-dropping federal deficit
estimated at more than 354 billion
dollars this fiscal year and inflation
at levels we haven't seen in more than a
decade political observers say that on
money matters liberals are in the hot
seat they've got a record they've got
six years that they have to account for
so it makes them particularly vulnerable
the pandemic has disproportionately
hammered young workers we've been
through a global recession we've
graduated when there weren't many jobs
and we've been rebuilding ever since and
then we dealt with a global pandemic
millennials and gen z now make up the
biggest cohort of eligible voters so i
think affordability anxiety when it
comes to millennials is really our fear
around not having enough dollars to
stretch between homeownership costs
paying off student loan debt caring for
aging parents and as well as their own
retirement savings needs
the party that can convince voters it
will make life more affordable may be
rewarded when it's time to cast ballots
ann gaviola global news toronto
next a small gesture catches the eye of
a big nba star
if you shoot hoops in your driveway or
backyard you've probably fantasized
about making a slam dunk that sends the
crowds wild well one edmonton teenager
could do nothing but dribble on his
driveway he didn't have a hoop until a
neighbor decided to step in and as sarah
comedina reports that kind gesture
snowballed into something no one ever
expected
outside of his north edmonton home
anthony mobike can be seen dribbling
every day sometimes hours at a time i'm
just
dribbling my driveway that's all the 14
year old did because he didn't have a
net to shoot at and the neighbors
noticed i come outside and then i see
like a man i barely ever see like ever
so like and then he's just like hey you
like playing basketball i'm like yes
that man is ian ray he lives across the
street i know he can dribble the ball i
haven't seen him shoot the ball yet i
thought whenever i dribbled
it made a rocket and people want to
sleep or something like that the noise
didn't bother his neighbors instead they
wanted to nurture his talent ian made a
facebook post looking for help to get
him a hoof your mom said he wanted to be
a basketball player
come here you probably need a nap
canadian tire stepped in with a new hoop
and basketball donations already
collected went towards a 750
sport check gift card i'll be in the mba
2026 i'll be there
and then try and give back to those
people and i will make them all proud
anthony is already making an impression
his story has already been viewed more
than a million times online a recruiter
at a private toronto school has reached
out with an offer to take part in a
basketball program next year it brought
his mom to tears my heart is full of joy
i'm overwhelmed i don't know what to say
i don't know what to
like all i can say is thank you so much
perhaps the most surreal moment a shout
out from anthony's idol nba superstar
lebron james who posted on instagram
anthony keep working kid you have
another fan in me lebron is my
inspiration that's him right there
that's the main lebron is the main
reason why
i started playing basketball now he has
the hoop to fulfill his dreams all
thanks to the generosity of his
community
sarah comedina global news edmonton
and that's global national for this
friday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is bell island in conception bay
newfoundland and labrador we'd love to
see your canada please email it to
viewers at
thanks for watching jeff semple will be
at the anchor desk over the weekend and
i will see you again on monday take care
of yourselves
[Music]
you